[Musique]
et pourant débat consomme avec m'hamed
kaki président de l'association
mémorielle les oranje bonsoir mais merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés franck
crudo contributeur au site causeur qui
s'est exprimé dans une tribune ce matin
sur ce sujet merci messieurs d'être
venus débattre sur cette question cette
polémique même si on l'a vu à l'elysée a
tenté un rétro pédalage mais pour vous
ces propos fortuit voulu m'hamed kaki
comment on les avait ressenti je leur ai
sont surtout dans un contexte politique
particulier qui sont dans un mois et
demi des élections municipales et le
président de la république est coutumier
du fait que de draguer un certain nombre
d' électorat dont l'électorat des
français héritiers de l'immigration
coloniale et donc dans ce contexte là je
ne suis pas étonné de cette erreur ou
cette confusion des histoires qui est
bien évidemment je le dis d'emblée ça
n'a rien à voir
histoire des crimes coloniaux et
l'histoire de la shoah sont des
histoires différentes dans des contextes
historiques complètement différent
néanmoins
l'histoire coloniale nous allons aussi
en parler là se pose est est une
histoire aussi très importante et qui ne
s'arrête pas seulement à ce qu'on
appelle la guerre d'algérie c'est à dire
le 1er novembre 1954 au a jusqu'en 1962
c'est bien plus large que ça l'histoire
coloniale en algérie a démarré en 1830
franquin crée donc votre réaction à ces
propos d' emmanuel macron avec y compris
le rétropédalage un qui va avec
oui alors bon je vous avoue je sais plus
trop quoi penser du président c'est ce
que je vous disais à l'instant à
l'antenne ce que j'ai quand même le
sentiment qu'il s'adapte un peu à son
auditoire et il est capable de dire tout
et son contraire en fonction de
l'endroit où ils se trouvent face à des
gens de gauche il a tendance à gauchisé
son discours des gens de droite à
droitiser en algérie nous parle de
crimes contre l'humanité là maintenant
effectivement pour la shoah il tient un
discours totalement différent bon bah
c'est ce qu'on appelle le en même temps
de la creuse mais ça peut être aussi ses
limites parfois alors le chef de l'état
en tous cas s'est dit convaincu que la
france devait je cite revisiter la
mémoire de la guerre d'algérie pour
mettre un terme au conflit mémorielle
qui rend la chose très dur en france il
parlait du statut un de jacques chirac
en 1995 lors de la reconnaissance de la
rafle du vel d'hiv est ce que ça vous
choque ça de m le même statut à s'en
faire le parallèle entre ces deux ces
deux événements dramatiques mais est ce
que est ce que on est là est ce qui est
une forme de sincérité selon vous quand
même ma mère kathy écouter les analogies
sont pas toujours fortuite
c'est toujours compliqué quand on
commence à faire des analogies des
rapprochements
il faut je crois à laisser le travail
aux historiens qui le font très bien et
il faut s'en inspirer d'abord ils font
un travail rigoureux et je pense que
c'est effectivement une erreur mais en
même temps
et vous connaissez ma position emmanuel
macron gelé combattu notamment pour le
mouvement social et pour les retraites
eh bien je crois que là il a sur
notamment il a avancé sur un certain
nombre de choses notamment la
reconnaissance pour un maurice audin la
veuve de maurice audin vous savez
qu'elle a même eu un accident un travail
et autour d'elle une association
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle morrison a
exactement les téléspectateurs qui
maurice audin c'est un mathématicien qui
était en algérie et qui avait pris fait
et cause pour les algériens pour contre
la torture contre les exactions contre
toutes ces humiliations et le poison
général de la colonisation et il a été
kidnappé on va dire par l'armée
française à l'époque et il a disparu
il a disparu alors on sait que il a été
torturé à mort par un certain nombre de
gens effectivement des militaires est
aujourd'hui le fait que le président de
la république a reconnu qu'il y avait
bel et bien que maurice audin a été
assassiné avec c'est un véritable crime
et qu'il n'est pas mort comme ça disparu
et bien c'est à c'est une avancée
importante non seulement pour le savoir
la connaissance mais aussi pour tous les
gens qui sont morts pour rien et ça je
pense que bien que ce soit l'adversaire
nous lui devons cette reconnaissance là
et c'est une avancée à la fois pour la
science mais aussi pour l'apaisement
ce cas là parce que qu'est ce qu'on
recherche des sons recherche ici c'est
aussi créer les conditions du
rapprochement entre les peuples entre le
peuple français et les deux rives de la
méditerranée comme on dit elle peuple
algérien qui sont tout à fait prêts
d'ailleurs les peuples non non non pas
j'allais dire de haine entre les seins
autre et donc c'est ça qui est important
et je crois qu'il faut lui reconnaître
cette cette initiative qui étaient
importantes
cependant on est loin du compte le
compte n'est pas là notamment sur la
question de la reconnaissance des crimes
coloniaux en algérie alors évidemment
qui comme je le disais tout à l'heure
ils ont commencé avec le général du joug
fameuse phrase tuez les tous qui n'en
reste pas un seul avec le 8 mai 1945 où
il ya eu 45 mille morts entre le 8 mai
1945 et le 30 septembre 1945
c'est un désastre sans compter les
spoliations le fait d'affamer les
peuples le peuple
le fait de détruire les structures du
savoir 1 parce que ça a eu des effets
sur la colonisation c'est une chose d'un
véritable poison
hier comme aujourd'hui parce que la
colonisation n'est pas terminée dans le
monde et en même temps elle a eu des
effets importants pour les générations
qui sont arrivés parce que vous avez ça
alors que l'algérie est un pays de
savants et bien on en a fait à l'époque
on a tout détruit les le comment dire
l'armée française à des prix beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
et effectivement je crois que
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est du passé bien
sûr mais il faut reconnaître et la
reconnaissance
chère madame n'est pas la repentance on
va en parler à tout à l'heure je vous
propose d'écouter tout d'abord un
historien jean sévillia historien
essayiste pour qui cette comparaison
emmanuel macron entre la shoah et la
guerre d'algérie s'apparente à de la
folie sur le plan historique affirmé que
la guerre d'algérie pourrait avoir à peu
près le même statut que celui qu'avait
la shoah pour chirac en 95 semble
annoncer une reconnaissance de
culpabilité de la france dans la guerre
d'algérie
ce à quoi se sont opposés tous les
présidents qui ont précédé emmanuel
macron quoi qu'on en pense
c'est de la folie sur tous les plans
historique politique et diplomatique
le simple énoncé de cette idée est
obscène d'abord par rapport à la shoah
qui perd alors sa singularité et son
ampleur sur le plan numérique la shoah
c'est près de six millions de morts
la guerre d'algérie c'est entre 250 et
300 mille morts dans les deux camps
franck renaud est ce qu'on peut dire
quand même ça eu le mérite de
lancé le débat où vous trouver
effectivement que c'est complètement
incongrues ce genre de comparaison même
encore une fois s'il ya eu de vrais
tropez dommage depuis
l'analogie entre la guerre d'algérie et
la shoah
même le terme de crimes contre
l'humanité un des propos qu apparemment
le président a assumé en tout cas n'a
pas regretté me semble effectivement
pour le moins assez choquant vous savez
moi je me méfie toujours des curseurs
qu'on pousse trop loin
quel que soit ce sujet d'ailleurs d'un
côté comme de l'autre si on faisait
partie d'un pays qui célébrait son
histoire avec une certaine arrogance
arrogance pardon sans aucun recul sans
aucun esprit critique y compris envers
ces heures sombres
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il faudrait
peut-être effectivement faire un devoir
de mémoire
essayez de s'interroger sur ces heures
sombres mais a contrario si on fait
partie d'un pays et j'ai un peu peur que
ça soit le cas aujourd'hui qui pousse
les curseurs très loin en termes de
repentance de discours de surenchère de
concurrence victimaire avec tous les
effets pervers que cela peut provoquer
ça je suis pas complètement d'accord
avec ce que vous venez de dire vous êtes
là pour débattre
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on pousse
tellement loin le curseur dans la
victimisation notamment la repentance
l'autoflagellation que ça pour effet
pervers notamment de 2 comment dire de
de créer encore plus de ressentiment
notamment vers des populations
certaines communautés à notre égard là
où me semble-t-il il faudrait peut-être
rééquilibrer plutôt le curseur et 10
rebonds
on va peut-être y allez un petit peu
plus mollo sur la repentance ou le la
victimisation et essayer de faire
émerger terminé à ce regard oui mais
essayez de faire peut-être aimé un peu
plus à notre pays à tomber oui oui vous
répondre et finissait voilà non mais
écoutez
voilà j'ai dit l'essentiel je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être essayé de faire
est minable davantage notre pays aux
gens issus de l'immigration aux jeunes
issus de l'immigration plutôt qu'à
chaque fois de leur donner des raisons
de détester
surtout que ces analogies ou ce discours
me semble extrêmement discutable sur le
plan intellectuel et terriblement contre
productive voire dangereux alors je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec ça mais
c'est votre position moi je crois
d'abord en termes d walsh ce qu'ils
disaient les mots font le monde et vous
savez moi je n'aime pas le mot issu de
je pense que nous sommes les français
héritier c'est un héritage est un
héritage de combat un héritage important
et la deuxième chose qui très importante
que nos téléspectateurs doivent savoir
c'est que cette histoire de l'histoire
coloniale n'est pas le fait de
l'histoire des algériens ou des
malgaches ou ou dans n'importe quel pays
qui a été colonisé c'est l'histoire de
france et donc les français sont amputés
d'une grande partie de leur histoire et
qu'il faut leur restituer d'un point de
vue scientifique c'est déjà ça le
problème
et moi quand je rencontrais des amis
avec qui j'ai grandi parce qu'on est
tous des français et bien qu'ils
connaissent pas cette porte de
l'histoire je trouve ça malheureux est
dommageable simplement pour la question
de l'histoire ça ses premiers points et
j'ai dit tout à l'heure où ils ont
effectué tout à l'heure tu en dis
monsieur j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la
reconnaissance n'est pas la repentance
la reconnaissance a justement pour but
la question de l'altérité latérite et
c'est quoi c'est faire en sorte
l'autre existe et si vous dites est bien
que la reconnaissance c'est la
repentance il ya nécessairement
l'impliquent pas nécessairement l'aube
selon vous un maître kaki quand on
reconnaît d'une certaine manière on se
repentit non pas du tout justement je
récuse totalement cette dialectique là
que je connais bien qui fait partie de
tout un pan politique de la société
française c'est ctu derrière ça il ya
toute une stratégie 1
alors je vous fais pas de procès le sua
vous mais je sais que d'ailleurs c'est
très curieux
on n'a pas relevé depuis tout à l'heure
quand même quel jeu quelles sont les
personnes qui se sont élevés contre de
manière violente contre monsieur macro
et bien c'est la droite et l'extrême
droite
or en matière de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
on peut faire mieux rappelez vous
monsieur le pen avec la sphère du détail
1 par rapport à la shoah c'est quand
même un scandale qui a land politique
oui mais ça continue
vous savez ce sont des artères défilent
et ça continue au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est toujours associé sa fille marine
le pen puisqu'on parle d'elle puisque
c'est la présidente aujourd'hui du
rassemblement national élite hier du fn
vous vous la mettez entre nîmes et dans
le même sac que son père il ya eu
effectivement ces mots - c'est toujours
la même mouvance de l'extrême droite
violente et qui justement jour et
n'aurait pas vraiment de l'état et qui
met la droite c'est pareil
vous avez deux droite les républicains
et
non non non justement il ya deux droites
pour moi il ya celle du général de
gaulle qui a combattu le nazisme le
fascisme et cela chapeau bas et puis
vous avez les vichystes vous avez le
général le maréchal pétain et vous avez
tous ceux qui ont enlevé la nationalité
française aux juifs faut se rappeler de
ça 1 ceux qui ont balancé les juifs au
nazis et bien tous ces nostalgiques là
il reste encore il existe encore et des
qu'effectivement il ya une ouverture de
dialogue
et encore une fois on sait pas mon
copain mais il a agi nous interrompt est
ce que pour vous l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui en france ni en premier lieu
d' extrêmement at il ensuite
eh bien il vient de partout mais
l'extrême droite
on sait très bien c'est justement où ils
font france depuis 1945 à 31 lancers
importants ces technologies fait c'est
l'extrême nord c'est l'idéologie ces
vidéos logis véhiculée par l'extrême
droite notamment violents d'extrême
droite qui tuer les juifs en france de
da dont on a très envie de bien évident
c'était les généreux et pas seulement à
lhassa évidemment là aussi ça vient
aussi d'autres notre part mais
principalement la question de
systématiquement d'une part de ses
banques et de l'élan la question de
bidules jean alex droits des musulmans
radicaux qui ont tué les juifs de près
de 75 en un seul neurone droite aux
escarmouches ça c'est totalement fou ah
ça c'est totalement faux oui en ce
moment faut il ya des gens qui se disent
à biais de deux des vêtements de l'islam
mais qui n'ont rien à voir avec l'islam
et enfin j'ai mon pendant en revanche il
son logement sans l'entente ne sont pas
desservis d'extra non c'est pas mes amis
les biens et bien eux
moi je vous rassure intitulé à véhiculer
à écouter vendredi
vous pourquoi vous dites que mes amis
d'un stage et un rejet de toute forme de
me semble que le journal dans lequel
vous êtes quand même a toujours la même
obsession c'est à dire l'islamophobie
c'est à dire la haine à la musulmane
sujet des effectifs comprends que vous
refusiez cette idée d'amalgamé on vous
comprend bien mais vous réfutez
aujourd'hui qui est un antisémitisme
voilà ce nouvel antisémitisme comme on
dit qui vient effectivement de l'islam
aujourd'hui en france est ce que vous le
contester slam pas de l'islam
des gens qui se revendique soul et la
cagoule de l'islam et donc ça il faut
faire attention à ce que michael a
justement ce que vous venez de dire mais
sans les savez il ya des gens qui
utilisent ne sont pas musulmans ils se
prétendent non ils sont pas musulmans
parce que parce qu'à vrai musulman ne
tue pas un vrai musulman ne n'assassine
pas un vrai musulman c'est quelqu'un qui
a de l'amour et de et qui veulent la
paix et donc la vérité monsieur l'accord
n'ont pas de confusion mais ce sont
effectivement mais j'essaye de suivre
votre raisonnement donc du coup marc
dutroux n'est pas belge adolf eichmann
n'est pas allemands parce que
l'allemagne ses yeux tu sais tu
mais j'ai l'impression vous avez une
vision idéalisée des choses dans un
monde idéal par me dire que l'islam n'a
rien à voir avec l'islamisme ce ne sont
pas des musulmans c'est un débat vieux
comme le monde mais là c'est quand même
un ce titre là le casser du suédois qui
a qui a assassiné des gens est us qu'il
représente l'ensemble des suédois un
norvégien soja norvégien pardon le
norvégien 1 et dans chaque pays il y a
des gens qui sont des fous ils ont trimé
dans l'hémisphère c'est de l'impasse la
vision qu'ils n'avaient l'islam c'est
pas parce qu'ils se revendique au nom de
coeur et d'ailleurs monsieur d'ailleurs
le débat ici c'est pas l'islam d'accord
si vous le voulez bien on va revenir
peut-être quand même sur la question
bien sûr cette l'idée en tout cas les
prud'hommes été
mettez en avant ce côté weir pendant ce
pour finalement divisé les uns et les
autres
est ce que il n'ya pas de ça aux six
mètres qui est ce qu'il faut reconnaître
se repentir peut-être est-ce qu'il ya
pas une fille ça n'entraîne pas
forcément une division mettre les uns
contre les autres faire forcément de
caen à votre avis vous qui justement
être vrai pour la paix et stéphanie
c'est justement là c'est l'objet de mon
travail c'est moi je avec mes amis en
oeuvre pour la reconnaissance pour la
reconnaissance du savoir pour le fait
qu'on se casse parce qu'on est tous
français et que on vit sept ans comme un
ensemble à travers notre république et à
l'intérieur de laquelle tous les projets
que je mène par exemple les
conférences-débats restée bloc mais
aussi le théâtre on a c'est pour faire
en sorte que les jeunes français
puissent acquérir cette connaissance de
l'histoire
mais comment leur cache une grande
partie de cette histoire là notamment
les médias parce que moi je vais vous
raconter quelque chose tout à l'heure
qui m'a porté sur se pétant j'ai eu un
prof d'histoire-géo spécialiste de la
choix puisque on parle évidemment de cet
événement à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la libération des camps
qui nous disait en terminale on laisse
aux professeurs le fait de choisir entre
l'enseignement de la mémoire de la
guerre d'algérie et l'enseignement de la
mémoire de la shoah
c'est un prof d'histoire-géographie un
qui m'a dit oui sur ce plateau
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque sa alors
moi ce qui évoque surtout c'est que
l'éducation nationale mais de moins en
moins de moyens à même assez singulier
mais entre les longs des gens oui c'est
aberrant c'est aberrant qu'on puisse
avoir le choix soit la guerre d'algérie
soit la joie faut connaître les deux il
faut connaître les deux est par ailleurs
c'est c'est aussi la question du budget
parce que vous savez qu'ils ont resserré
les boulons et qu'aujourd'hui la
l'enseignement de l'histoire et peau de
chagrin et peau de chagrin au lycée au
collège etc et donc au détriment de
dudar serrage de boulons d'une manière
générale et je crois que ça c'est un
vrai problème et ça ne devrait pas
exister ce que vous dites c'est un autre
débat je trouve ça assez troublant mois
se joue son va vous aller enseigner la
shoah julien dran jamie c'est aberrant
c'est aberrant il faut l'histoire c'est
la connaissance est ce qui nous
permettent de nous connaître
et puis d'être j'allais dire de se
comprendre et même si on n'est pas
d'accord quelquefois mais en tout cas de
nous comprendre et et l'histoire et les
sciences sociales en général ça permet
ça permet cela et je crois que c'est
dommageable
donc l'histoire coloniale qui est très
mal enseignée moi ce que je voulais
c'est souligner quand même une chose
très importante c'est le nombre de morts
entre 1830 et 1962 parce que moi je ne
me concentre pas uniquement sur
l'histoire de la guerre d'algérie qui a
duré entre 54 et 62
vous savez la violence avec laquelle
s'est mise en place la politique de
peuplement en algérie est inouïe c'est à
dire la spoliation le fait d'affamer les
gens le fait de les exterminer
d'une manière générale d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est à dire quand vous
affamer les frais de vous répondre parce
qu'il ya un peu plus de temps de parole
s'il veut dire de votre le terme
d'extermination déjà est extrêmement
connoté si je peux me permettre
oui un peu effrayant mais je vois
beaucoup de choses
oui parce qu'on part d'histoire
coloniale oui ça c'est surtout
l'analogie avec la shoah
fête à la gorge et moi oui enfin c'est
le un peu le sujet et c'est la nage
l'analogie qu'a fait le président de
macron est-ce que vous par exemple
justement puisque vous parler de ce
sujet est ce que vous estimez que la
guerre d'algérie est un crime contre
l'humanité la part de la france alors
vous reprendriez les propos du président
moi je parle de crime colonial et ma
crimes contre l'humanité en coloniale
c'est à dire que la question de crime
colonial s'est il y a des choses qui
ressemblent donc ça dépend des périodes
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
compliqué on dialogue avec les
historiens etc
il faut ans de ce point de vue là et
bien les crimes coloniaux ça consistait
notamment à une période donnée vous avez
le général du jour lorsque lui avec les
enfumades ce que vous connaissez les
enfumades quand on a enfermé les gens
dans les grottes et faire des feux à
l'entrée des de ces grottes et que les
gens mouraient comme ça ça a été
terrible donc il y a eu des moments où
il ya eu des processus d'extermination
mais il ya eu d'autres moments beaucoup
plus apaisé on va dire ne nous les a
calmés y ait pas de crime contre lui je
ne parlerai pas de crimes coloniaux
contre l'humanité systématique dac
en revanche il y a eu des moments dans
l'histoire coloniale en algérie où il a
eu des processus d'extermination il
faudrait un côté benjamin stora pardon
va vous allez répondre en credo parce
qu'il nous reste peu de temps
l'historien qui affirme lui l'absence de
procès sur ce conflit algérien est un
véritable obstacle à la réconciliation
si on veut comparer avec la question de
la shoah
outre le travail historique les procès
celui de klaus barbie ou de maurice
papon ont été de formidable accélérateur
des moments de cristallisation de
dévoilement historique des réalités
l'absence de procès sur le conflit
algérien est un véritable obstacle
réconcilie les mémoires n'est d'ailleurs
pas qu'un enjeu mémoriel
c'est une nécessité historique l'algérie
est un grand pays
une clé pour de nombreux enjeux comme la
question migratoire ou le terrorisme
on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir des
relations ambiguës avec ce pays
fran credo vous critiquiez ce côté auto
flagellation est ce qu'un procès ça
serait pas effectivement là
la première solution pour apaiser les
sur la guerre d'algérie
oui notamment sur la guerre d'algérie on
va terminer là dessus oui enfin moi
l'absence de procès je regrette c'est
surtout celui c'est un autre sujet mais
enfin ça le rejoint un peu sur madame
admis sur son meurtre
ça j'aurais bien aimé qu'il y ait un
procès notamment
enfin il vient dans la neige oui et non
parce que il ya quand même un petit
rapport avec notice ya aussi en fait oui
mais on parle justement des bienfaits
d'un process je pense qu'à ce titre est
d'ailleurs le président de macron la
livre qui est lui-même en israël mais
moi si vous voulez j'essaye de
comprendre votre raisonnement en fait et
est ce que j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question à monsieur k qui est ce
que pour vous la france est la seule
responsable des atrocités durant la
guerre d'algérie ou est-ce que les torts
sont partagés selon vous écouter la
france a colonisé l'algérie donc la
première responsabilité c'est d'abord
que l'avenir d'abord oui et elle a
détruit des écoles à la détruit des
universités elle a fracassé un pays
pendant 132 ans
parce que si on veut revenir elle a
aussi construit les écoles et galodé
pour qui pour qui les européens
ella ella elle a créé un cercle
géographiques et toutes les terres
arables barrabes arables qui qui était
cultivables elle a laissé les indigènes
crever dedans elle est donc
donc si vous voulez c'est pour ça que
c'est extrêmement compliqué
c'est d'une violence inouïe et
d'ailleurs je dois dire que nos anciens
sont bien gentils ils nous ont transmis
que de l'amour c'est ça qui est
formidable je veux dire qu'avec la rue
en elle la violence qui a eu avec
l'avenant et l'avait ans qu'ils ont
subis des anciens en transmis toujours
l'idée qu'il fallait dialoguer et
continuer
puis votre raisonnement la france est
avant tout coupable d'avoir colonisé
cette terre qui n'est pas elle
donc du coup vous seriez prêt également
à demander pardon pour la colonisation
de l'espagne par exemple par les
musulmans pendant huit siècles par la
colonisation par les ottomans d'une
partie de la roche sur yon monsieur je
suis français oui je ne suis pas parce
que là vous me demandez qui vous dit que
je suis musulman je vais attendre et là
on est en tant que la question de ma
position et vivent elles vous ne me
regarde personne ici d'accord ici je
suis en attente le riz c'est normalement
demande pardon également pour la
colonisation n'est ce d'ailleurs par
ailleurs les jurés pendant seulement par
ailleurs lui musulman du point de vue de
l'histoire parce que plus une animation
sont condamnables si je suis votre
raisonnement
monsieur non seulement la colonie des
musulmans d'espagne ont justement ont
aidé les chalets sur la lande à 12 jeux
de ce débat sur des sujets parfois
effectivement sensible mais voilà il y
avait deux à viesly contradictoires
c'était l'essentiel merci à vous deux on
se retrouve dans